joining us now the health section is
sergey javid twice in a week you're
spoiling me mr javid um talk to me about
this new nhs report uh leaders praise
for their dedication but it does find
that bullying discrimination and
shifting the blame when things go wrong
arrive in the nhs why is that
well today we're announcing what i think
is the biggest shake-up in leadership in
the nhs and social care generation it
follows this independent review by
general sir gordon messenger and and why
we've done this is really we're
investing record amounts in the nhs in
care and to help with the recovery from
the pandemic it's important that we have
good leadership throughout the nhs and
care so that every pound is spent well
on patients priorities and what this
report shows is that i mean first of all
and that's the best news is that there
are fantastic examples throughout the
nhs in care of of great leadership and i
see that almost every day but there are
also examples of of poor leadership and
that leads to poor patient outcomes so
it gives a number of recommendations on
how good leadership can be made more
consistent throughout the country it
also to your point uh it gives evidence
uh unfortunately of in some cases of
poor behavior a bit of a blame culture
in in certain parts and of course that
can't be tolerated so i'm going to
accept all the recommendations of this
independent report and
that's because i know that it's going to
lead to a significant improvement across
the board in leadership and management
in the nhs in care which most
importantly means an improvement in
patient outcomes okay now i'm sure
you'll see in this morning's papers that
uh
nhs advice on ovarian cancer on the
website has dropped the reference to it
affecting women what it actually says
now is ovarian cancer affects the two
small organs ovaries that store the eggs
needed to make babies why the change
well look um i i haven't seen that
particular report but i have heard of
instances like that and i don't think
it's right you know you won't be
surprised to know that as a health
secretary i think that your that your
your sex matters you know your
biological sex is incredibly important
to make sure you get the right treatment
the very best treatment you've given an
example of ovarian cancer i could
equally uh pick a prostate cancer which
which we know can only happen for those
that are biologically male and so
it's important that that when messaging
is is given to people you know for
cancers that's a great example that
you've picked that that words like women
and men are you so that people know who
you're talking about and and then we can
actually do something about it
are you gonna get the wording change
back then
well i i am looking into this and you
all know look the nhs there are many
different trusts and and i want to
listen to why someone might have taken a
different approach i don't just want to
assume but i think i've made my views
clear on this yeah but it's actually on
the nhs website so you know and and as
we both know as many of our viewers will
know ovarian cancer is a silent killer
generally a lot of women don't that
kills a lot of women in their 30s 40s
50s because they don't know they've got
it until they're at stage four and then
there's nothing that can be done about
it when you have confusing wording like
that it's just not going to help so
don't you think well i'm guessing what
you're saying
yeah go on okay look i i agree and uh
and also you know a few months back a
similar issue came up over cervical uh
cancer where you know i saw some
in that case it was it was
literature around getting more uh women
encouraging to come in for smear tests
and and it was important of course to
talk about women when you're talking
about cervical cancer and believe it or
not there are women out there that don't
know always that when you're talking
about cervixes and things you're
actually talking about women and and the
way you do that is make sure that you're
using the right and the sensible words
so
i know there's some sensitivity around
this language but we have to use common
sense and use the right language so that
we can give people the best possible
patient care okay so that wording should
be changed back let's wait and see what
happens thanks for the clarification on
that health secretary uh rail strikes
let's talk about those three in a week
at the end of the month it's going i
mean we're just trying to get ourselves
back on our feet as a country and as an
economy what's the government going to
do about it
look
we obviously don't agree with this
decision of the unions i think it's it's
not just clearly a bad outcome for
travellers if these strikes went ahead i
actually think it's bad for for the
workers because
you need it and have an industry that's
that's going to be sustainable we know
as a result of the pandemic there are
some habits that that are developed and
things might not go quite back to what
they were pre-pandemic and and let's
remember during the pandemic i think the
government put in some extra 16 billion
pounds to support the rail industry
that's almost something like 600 pounds
per household these are these are huge
amounts of money and that kind of thing
can't continue so what i would urge the
industry uh to do and and and the unions
is to basically just get round the table
and keep talking that's the best way
just talk like you civilize adults and
find a way through i think everyone can
understand each other and these are
challenging times but talk
what about fuel up to two pounds at
least now this time last year it was one
time 30 a liter the government making
something like 26 billion pounds in fuel
duty is it time to look at cutting
uh the price the fuel duty further i
know you've already done five pence a
liter well look what we know the the
fuel duty was as you mentioned it was
cut very recently by the chancellor
that's the biggest cut and
fuel detail i can ever remember and and
that does cost the treasury billions and
and and and i hear what you say about
your fuel duty raises i think you said
26 billion or thereabouts but
at the end of the day we also have to
remember that uh you know i'm standing
in this hospital today and i've talked
about investing billions in in nhs and
care the nhs's budget uh this year is
something like 160 billion pounds and
that money has to come from somewhere so
it is right that we keep all taxes and
duties under review especially when
people are facing the cost of living
challenges it's right that we cut fuel
duty by 5p and i'm sure the chance will
be looking to do whatever else can be
afforded
over time
now i know you'll want to address this
allegation that labour's put forward
today so allow me to give you the
opportunity to do that they say they've
unearthed evidence of you avoiding
hundreds of thousands of pounds in tax
before you got into politics did you
well no of course not this is typical
labor you know personal attacks on on
people and this is what labor does when
they've got nothing to say about the the
real issues the issues at hand you know
what i yeah i think what people want to
know from labor is you know what are
their plans to deal with the nhs you
know kobe backlogs what are their plans
to help with cost of living what are
their plans for growth in the economy
this is just typical smear attacks by
labor and it's nothing more
okay what they say is that uh records
showed that you were a director of a
company set up by your brother for a
single day in may of 2005
and then you
gave up yours and your wife's shares
during that year sa capital raised
almost a million pounds in loans though
only 411 000 was secured from banks
leaving 585 000 unaccounted for 2005
accounts also show that 491 000 was lent
to an unknown party
the suggestion being that if the purpose
of the loans was to provide a tax
efficient way for money held offshore to
enter britain is that nonsense or is
there some uh truth in that well what i
i've i've been very clear about my own
tax affairs my tax states my residences
when i worked in the uk when i've worked
abroad i've been very clear and open
about that and at all times i've been
clear that your all rules of course have
always uh been followed and what labor
what you're referring to in in this
letter is this is just a typical sort of
labor smear campaign where they don't
have any evidence on anything and
they're just making things up so that
they can launch personal attacks that's
all it is let me ask you one more on
that and then we'll move on to the prime
minister if i may so 585 000 pounds
unaccounted for is the suggestion there
and potentially the purpose of the loans
to provide a tax-efficient way for money
held offshore to enter britain is there
any truth at all in that allegation
no i've what i what i've been clear
about and as i've said i've been very
open about
about all of this is that and yesterday
when i was asked about this for for the
first time uh is that you know some 20
years ago uh i did i invested in my
brother's business to help him start a
new business of course i did and i think
there's anything wrong with that i think
that's something that many people will
do to help out their siblings or or
loved ones in starting their own
business or their enterprise and and
that's all there is uh to this that's
all there is
okay so there was no way that money was
coming in from offshore without paying
the tax on it okay uh talk to me about
the um
prime minister and suggestions that he's
potentially going to promote he's going
to have a reshuffle i know you won't
comment on a reshuffle but suggestions
that he is potentially going to promote
people who have been incredibly
supportive um
publicly and privately over the last few
weeks does in your experience does the
prime minister
prioritize loyalty
over experience
the the
i mean first of all this is just all
speculation again we we've had a a a a a
very important week uh obviously with
that important vote it was a clear and
decisive win uh for the prime minister
and and and speaking to colleagues here
after that vote yesterday including some
that that i spoke to that that publicly
said they didn't support the prime
minister and the vote but you know
they're democrats like all of us and
they accept the result of the vote and
they're getting behind the prime
minister and what the prime minister
does next in terms of uh his you know
his cabinet his ministers that's of
course that's as always any prime
minister that's just a decision for them
i'm not spending any time speculating or
thinking about that i'm just getting on
with my job as the health and care
secretary and that's why i was here
today to talk about this new leadership
review indeed so and that's exactly why
i said to you i wasn't expecting you to
comment on it but nevertheless my
question was does the pm prioritise
loyalty over experience we've seen him
do it in the past in some of the
high offices of state is it your
experience that he prioritizes loyalty
well my experience is that he wants the
best people
in the right roles so that we can get on
with dealing with the huge challenges
especially post pandemic we face
as a country that's why i think for
example i was asked to to step into this
role it's for me it's the is that it's
the toughest job i've done in government
so far uh but it's also i'd say was one
of the most rewarding one most
privileged to work with such incredible
people but to help to deal with such
important challenges before i let you go
um is it right that the 1922 committee
could look again at the rules to change
the rules so instead of the prime
minister having a year's grace before he
would face any further
challenges against him it could be
reduced to six months is it right that
they move the goal posts
you know
i i i'm not sure uh to to perfectly
honestly i'm not an expert on
on the rules around the 22 uh committee
what i do know is that the the the rules
uh as they stand uh that uh that
you can't have another vote uh for a
year but look i mean
as i say i'm not an expert on the rules
but i think right here and now that
we've had had this uh ballot it was done
properly in a completely fair
transparent way the party of war has
expressed confidence in the prime
minister at his time now just to unite
and to get on with the job i didn't
think you were going to say that i
thought you were going to say absolutely
not
he's won the vote and he's safe for a
year
well i that's he i've just said to you
he's won the vote uh he's got the
confidence uh of the of the majority of
mps and that's how this works no prime
minister i've known in the past has had
the confidence 100
of mps there's a democratic uh decision
and that's why we're going to get on for
the with the job you know for for for
the years to come but you know let's
just get on with it i think that's what
people want to see i know you've got to
go but just to clarify that i'm not sure
what what did you mean when you said
you're not sure whether they should look
again at it
no i thought you asked me what are they
able uh to change the rules and my
answer to that
i'm not
should they change the real system of
course they should okay i
of course they shouldn't change the
rules i thought you were asking me
whether they can change them but uh yeah
there's no need to change any rules
because we've had the ballot it's a
clear decisive result and now we just
get on with the job oh i'm glad we
cleared that up that would have been a
headline later on today thank you very
much indeed for joining us health
secretary as always thank you thank you